[Musica]
la mia terra di fiabe ma ci credi a me
ai cammelli che va su e giù
brilla il sole da sud soffia il vento da
nord c'è un'intensa complicità
sul tappeto rava
dove andare lo sa delle nozze in oriente
andrà
scappa un pezzo di pane sono già qua
rubo solo quel che servirà tutto cane
non è il pane solo
[Musica]
guardiamo giu il bottino che ma la cittá
chiquita se il mio solo amico
no no no no
no no no
chiedi ma non è tutto ciò che vuole
una dico amico come legame e pavoni con
l'unione
le sue bestie sono veri gioielli
tu cos'è non so io lo so è un serraglio
di sangue blu
i principianti
si no
box in giù sempre più giù
mills
sì posso non per mera in prima fila sarà
spettacolo
ogni cosa che anche quella più bella
no non vale la stella
che fra poco toccherà il mondo
tra mille di amanda
un po debole è un mondo che
art
no
soltanto a
per me per cento
bonino
no
sono berno
a me
[Musica]